three points for the winner if they are
tied then it will be decided and tie
breaks two points for the winner and one
point for the loser and here we go here
we go and Ivanka is going to be very
happy Magnus opening with the karaoke
defense yet again I am extremely happy
my favorite opening on the board and I'm
a little bit worried because Magnus is
pausing there you go he hasn't shaken my
faith in the caracon and here comes the
light squared bishop and this is such a
trendy move right now just it's so
tricky as well and black normally hands
handles this H4 Push by actually copying
and once again the players are following
the fashion and now the light Square
Bishop comes out and offers a trade and
this is very very thematic he pushes the
e-pawn forward one square forward this
actually isn't the line that I recommend
or play but uh it is still very good
yeah lots of action are going to be on
the board pragma pragmatic prag
going for the most critical lines
delaying this queen move he does go for
it however after a bit of a think and we
might well see the players race down
that variation Magnus doesn't need to
rush by retreating his Queen uh he could
also for example bring out his Knight to
a very nice Square on F5 this is quite
thematic as well the dream home for
Black's night
well this isn't part of your repertoire
uh this exact yeah it is now after this
night move by Prague and you can see
Magnus has gone for the most thematic
approach which is developed the uh the
Knight to the F5 Square this is the
perfect square for such a knight in the
caracon and he offers a trade of Queens
again so far so good Magnus is doing all
the right things and he's breaking out
now he's challenging White's Pawn Santa
and this as a Cara player gives me great
joy because when you do this it's either
good as in really good or it's going to
be bad and here I think it's perfect
it's already one of them no and
certainly not and he does capture the
porn and as David indicated the bishop
captures and he's uh Prague is playing
in aggressive style directly attacking
the queen seizing space so I find that
this type of chess for white is quite
risky but also very ambitious at the
same time why is it risky people could
be asking me and that's primarily to do
with the pawn structure and the control
of the half open lines one of my
favorite games that I played in the
caracon as black was when I castled on
move 37 as black so I castled queen side
David yeah I think my opponent uh famous
commentator Janet vikrama he was he
nearly jumped out of his chair when I
Castle Queen side he forgot it was still
legal but uh yeah so often here I mean
that just kind of illustrates the fact
that Black's King doesn't necessarily
need to make a decision as long as the
center is blocked with pawns it is a
real mind-boggling one I think David
described it to me as one of the hardest
made in twos ever it is white to play
meanwhile Magnus just centralizes the
black Rook
also very sensible we could see a
puzzle-like finish to this game
potentially if Prague can't build up
some attack in the middle almost
um yeah essentially Magnus has
committed he's said I'm not going to
Castle queenside he's moved his Rook
across and that black Rook was attacked
by White's Bishop White's Bishop now
does look like a pretty decent piece
covering some key squares but
essentially the status quo has been
maintained the center is still closed
and we'll see the game enter a
maneuvering phase in the next few turns
the two greatest footballers uh playing
right now for sure this is a game
between Magnus Carlson and Hikaru
Nakamura from Norway chess and uh
meanwhile a long think now from Magnus
Carlson Prague has played a very
mysterious move the white Rook coming
across it's lining up against the black
queen buds it's not 100 clear what the
plan is for Prague Onslaught you really
need your queen there and wow after
almost six minutes
I thought that Magnus would actually
slow down the play and go backwards with
the queen just in anticipation of
White's porn move but instead he just
accelerates everything wow from push
pieces Advanced development once the
pawn reached is the eighth rank now
heavily armed with a tank my opponent's
base is threatened soldiers cut with
Shanks this is the kind of stuff that
very much inside the space of hip-hop
but you're not always going to see it in
the pop artist so you know you gotta you
gotta dig for it but it's absolutely
there oh
about that how did that happen so
America needs more and young people need
more physical and mental balance right
so they work hard on Jiu Jitsu they work
hard on the chessboard the meditation
centers them to improve both and the
results have been fantastic there's a
measured way where if one grabs the
other there's a response if he knows it
if they do that response there are three
variant responses and these think it's
just like chess so for me chess is Jiu
Jitsu for the mind and Jujitsu is chest
for the body how how has that impacted
your students lives outside the academy
but when you got to rethink restructure
and and and refocus to win again that's
where I see the champion you know and so
I'm I'm inspired by him in in his uh in
his consistence returns Ivanka and I
were discuss in the position it feels
like Magnus he's managed to get over the
worst but he had to walk a bit of a
tightrope to get here and therefore
Magnus found a really important Retreat
he stepped his Knight back guarding that
diagonal so now the queen is stepping
forward for example wouldn't cut across
black could still safely Castle the king
and uh as we saw in the game it that
meant that Prague had nothing better
than Rook takes porn and magnus's King
finally does find safety uh he could
have prolonged that game maybe one on
the clock but uh yeah dude it feels like
things are going against him and
sometimes that's hard to turn that Trend
in chess yeah yeah and uh there we see
the night spring forward to the Santa
attacking the rook and The Rook Julie
moves to the fourth row so Prague is
potentially getting ready to switch over
to the right side if needed and attack
the black king throw the pieces even if
I want to punch the wall you know you
have to suppress it and that's why this
tool has been so refreshing we see the
players showing their passion all of
these guys they want to win more than
anything else in the world they don't
care about uh anything other than that
full point the victory you want to do
this immediately it's very risky but the
white Rook would be able to swing across
and there might be some threats against
the black king but this was not allowed
by Magnus he offered this exchange of
Rooks tying white down here and yes
White's retreated White's Knight wants
to aim into some juicier squares
potentially but Magnus has finally
activated his last piece and I think
that's a great sign the evaluation bar
agrees suddenly the position is turning
in Black's favor this black Rook maybe
shouldn't have been allowed into the
game and after a trade suddenly black is
the one Conquering the open file I I
agree with you that I mean Prague has
been very like one track he's playing
with a one-track mind he just wants to
attack on the right side
why should you yeah I think you called
it with this queen move that Magnus has
just chosen the black queen suddenly is
active tying white down to some pieces
over here some pawns on the left side if
White NOW does get greedy and grab this
pawn it feels like there should be
consequences I don't see it immediately
but White's attack still needs time to
build up as long as there's no Checkmate
against the black king then uh Magnus
should be happy enough and we're going
to see this critical variation this is
the acid test of what Magnus here is
doing and okay he does take the spawn so
both Queens have got greedy black queen
is far divorced as you coined uh from
its king so maybe that's one worrying
sign for black but white is only
attacking with a queen right now the
bishop doesn't really do anything uh
White's Bishop is hitting thinner it has
to be joined by the Knight
we are going to see Prague here go all
in it's as if he's thrown all of his
chips into the center he's saying I'm
going for checkmate I'm going for
something against the black king but the
two black knights will act as Defenders
and Magnus is calling the bluff he's
saying nope I don't care I'm just gonna
take all the Pawns
wow thank you I mean the evaluation bar
seems to say black is just almost
winning now
does that mean that Prague has just got
nothing maybe he's just hoping for
tricks and uh and then maybe trying to
jump in with the white knight but no
Prague does indeed just Shuffle his Rook
across he moves his Rook to D1 but what
is that doing is he getting ready to
sacrifice his Rook potentially yeah he
has to be I mean there's otherwise it's
just a very mysterious Rook move ignore
White's threats so uh oh and he doesn't
find any of the top three moves Magnus
does that give prag a winning move nope
it's just level again and it's back in
the balance it's all about whether Pride
can break through with a sacrifice if he
can't then he'll have to look for other
avenues maybe he'll now sidestep his
Rook to try and get in on the open C
file it's incredibly impressive from the
young Indian player
we thought just a few moves ago he was
running out of steam he was running out
of ideas but there he goes he drops back
the queen uh stockfish did confirm a few
moments ago that this was one of White's
best moves lining up the queen with the
black king some tricks there potentially
yeah and uh Magnus will now be
considering what Prague is threatening
and that's why he runs away with the
King because white was potentially
threatening to advance the H board maybe
come in to F6 with a peace sacrifice and
Magnus desperately trying to clarify the
situation he's keeping his King in
safety and at the same time oh and we
see Prague Retreat return the queen to
where she came from and so does the king
so will we see a draw by threefold
repetition if I were Prague I'm playing
against Magnus Carlson so I would take
the draw
I can't handle the tension and well
we're gonna see whether Magnus is
feeling ambitious and wants to play on
or is he satisfied with draw Magnus down
at around 30 seconds though it would be
so brief to take a risk now and not
repeat the position Black's King does
look like it's a Target but Magnus is
the one to reject the draw reject the
repetition he offers a trade of Rook
stepping back Black's Knight will he
live to regret that decision though
attacking chances black is one point up
though so if the Queens disappear those
two black pawns will win the game and
prague's giving up a piece he's dropped
his Bishop in the heart of Black's
position this is a peace sacrifice
because now after a rook trade
there's no more pin black can actually
that can maybe grab this bishop you have
to calculate this very carefully
can you just call pranks Bluff and take
this white Bishop off the board computer
seems to think black is winning
is Magnus reacting to this let's uh
sadness as well yeah we need to watch
both players here because the nerves
will be juggling for both of them he
doesn't bite the bullet he doesn't take
White's bishop and I think that was a
good decision if you had taken White's
Bishop the White Queen would have come
to the top of the board delivered a
nasty check but look at this black
Retreat blocking the white Queen's entry
points that night tree is such a good
offensive move and if that Bishop moves
well suddenly the E5 Pawn Falls and
Magnus is completely winning and the
queen slides over one square but Magnus
he's just forcing an in-game yeah he's
closing the door every time White's
Queen tries to get in behind the black
pieces Magnus shuts down either with his
queen or with his Knights black only has
good defensive pieces left and finally
he does get greedy he does seize the
moment to take White's Bishop so right
now black is a whole night ahead but
will the black king survive how does he
keep his King safe he said he tries to
run forward out into the open he's going
to keep advancing down the board and
he's counter-intuitive but it looks safe
enough for now there's no checks with
the White Queen White's Knight can give
a check however maybe that's what we'll
see Prague do yeah and I'm I'm actually
predicting that that Knight Will retreat
at the right time to age six and this is
why Prague just moved his Queen one
square to the side you know she's
threatening to give a check on age five
or a knight is going to jump in at all
Magnus using the whole board just to
defend his King look how the queen gave
a check and she returned all the way
back such classy move yeah really really
nice use of geometry there gives a check
with his Knight now Black's King has to
March into the eye line of the White
Queen this is with his uh look this was
the only safe Square sorry it's so
exciting right now but Prague the
problem is you can give a discover check
but Black's Queen will block and you're
just a night down no more compensation
you have to trade the queens and that
will spell the end yeah and now David's
saying they're reunited back to back
together again Magnus to actually
capture the Knight Queen takes and step
back with the queen and there we go
it is going to be game over there's just
really no way that the White Queen can
fight all alone against Black's Army I
mean just take a look at those two pawns
there the A and the B pawns they're just
gonna promote
the white king is on the wrong side of
the board you have to try this there's
simply nothing else for Prague but uh
the queen of night together for black
I'm just going to defend everything
they're going to hold everything if
black can force a queen trade that's
game over those two black pawns will
decide that's what Magnus is trying to
do planting his Knight in the center
unless there's some miraculous Perpetual
Trek now from pregnant then he can
essentially resign but look at this
Black's King yet again hides on the side
of the board and no more tracks the
clock is ticking for Prague and he
Retreats the king I mean there's really
nothing for it he just has to push his
pawns forward and hope for the best and
here comes Alice she's wandering down
the board
and we saw Prague shake his head he
knows that he's relying on a huge
blunder now also the clock times are
against him Magnus was down at a few
seconds when he was defending for his
life but he's built up a huge time
Advantage almost at the one minute Mark
now and again just centralizing his
Queen he's trying to say yes the White
Queen can go and capture Black's pawns
but then the white pawns would fall
see any any defensive idea here would
involve weakening the white king even
further pregnant under five seconds he
does try and grab a pawn but it's not
going to be enough Black's Queen and
Knight are gonna team up now maybe even
deliver some checkmating threats he's
got a safe place to hide the king queen
and Knight perfect attacking Duo and
he's following the principles putting
the queen in the center she's
controlling as many squares as possible
this is such a good technique and Prague
just 10 seconds left on the clock and
his position is dire
and in the background we see Wesley so
he has just won the first game today
against Jan Crist of Duda
that means hopes for Wesley so of
winning the tour finals
if Magnus loses the match today right
now that's not looking good for Wesley
Magnus about to win yeah and this is the
danger when you don't attack correctly
and when the attack Fizzles out you
might just be material down and here we
do see as Ivanka advocated Black's King
is going to start marching forward why
not white is attacking with only a queen
the safest way to avoid the checks is to
hide behind the white pawns uh to hide
behind your own pieces potentially and
uh here black can just munch on that
white H Pawn very safely and the checks
will start to dry up only one move that
Magnus must not play he must not step
forward with his King to the G4 square
if he does that he's gonna lose he's
going to get checkmated but Magnus he's
too clever he just centralizes the queen
and uh yeah that's it we have a result
Magnus has won the first game with the
black pieces taking the lead here minus
Carlson